Is there any harm in taking anti-dose enzyme therapy to my protocol? I've
been reading your information on Dr. Gonzales. So Dr. Nicholas Gonzales was one of my teachers.
He was a great guy. I liked him a lot and he was a protege. Dr. William Kelly. Well he took a lot
information from Dr. William Kelly and he wrote several books on Dr. William Kelly. And he believed
highly in high dose enzyme therapy. So he developed a product with allergy research that's called
pancreas pork and it's using pork enzymes. Very high dose. And the theory was that very high dose
enzymes take it on an empty stomach or relatively empty stomach. You'd absorb them.
No, typically you take enzymes to help digest your food but this is taking enzymes in excess
that then you'd absorb these enzymes and these enzymes would work in your body. They can help
clean up, you know, clean up waste in your body but the real purpose with somebody with cancer would
be to help break down the waste layer that's around the cancer so that any other therapy can
attack the cancer. So is there any danger in taking using high dose enzyme therapy for someone?
No, I don't think in general. No, I don't think there is a danger for anybody using high dose enzyme
therapy. Is there downsides to high dose enzyme therapy? Well, just about a pill that you have to
swallow depending on when high dose you're going. Dr. Gonzales used to have people take upwards of 75
in the morning and 75 in the evening. But you don't have to go that high of a dose to still get some
benefits of relative high dose therapy. But I don't see any negatives to doing any high dose enzyme
therapy. You could make a giant argument. I think I have a video out there somewhere I talked
about this a couple years ago, some research that came out that studied the different CT scans and
MRIs of the general populace that they came to a working prognosis that people have it enlarged
a pancreas. It was a study on why is pancreatic cancer rates going up. And they said that
study showed that there that people in general have a much larger pancreas than the previous
generations. And the theory was is that we're eating more chemicals in our foods that our
denatured enzymes in the gut and therefore our pancreas is forced to enlarge to make more enzymes
and there were having a relative decrease in enzyme utility and functionality. And therefore that's
partly of what it can be causing disease and partly what can be leading to inflammation in the
pancreas and therefore dysfunction and eventually cancer. So I don't know how much that theory has been
proven but it does make sense from a working hypothesis that we do put a lot of stress on our pancreas
and I have thought often about why functional medicine doctors from many years ago have recommended
using pancreatic enzymes and have had success with not with cancer patients which is the general
populace. It's because our pancreas is already straight and most people haven't a pancreatic insufficiency.
So that's the inability of the pancreas to keep up with the production of enzymes needed to help
clean out the gut and digest food partially because our food is so adulterated. So you can't
argue with that whole theory because it's been proven to be true from a functional standpoint.
So adding more enzymes to your protocol could never be harmful per se.